[Music]
tis the season for Blake Shelton Reba
McEntire Kacey Musgraves and so many
more happy Friday y'all and happy
holiday season today we are counting
down some of our favorite country songs
that will hopefully get you in the
Christmas spirit let's get right to it
with one of my favorite contemporary
offerings from Kacey Musgraves
[Music]
of Mary Kacie Christmas is delivered in
the singers signature style and also
features collaborations with Leon
bridges and Willie Nelson up next brat
Eldridge gets an assist from pop star
Meghan Trainor on a classic for his
Christmas album
[Music]
ah beautiful Chris this standard gets a
gorgeous acapella upgrade with Rascal
Flatts version of I'll be home for
Christmas please have snow and mistletoe
and presents under the tree
[Music]
alright let's be honest there is no way
this list would be complete without a
little dolly and Kenny if their
Christmas to remember TV special isn't
already on your holiday watchlist it
should be
[Music]
when it comes to King George Strait
there's no shortage of Christmas
offerings but you guys at home told me
that jingle bell rock off his 1999 album
is one of your favorites so here it is
jingle bells swing and jingle bells ring
snowing and blowing up bushels
now the jingle hop has begun and yes if
you like your classics delivered with
some soul Chris Young has got it covered
on his 2016 album it must be Christmas
the full-length also features
collaborations with Brad Paisley Alan
Jackson and even voice 2 met
[Music]
the snows coming down
[Music]
watch it fall
[Music]
people around
[Applause]
[Music]
now when Martina McBride's shows up to
the very special Christmas party the
woman needs no introduction
[Music]
Oh Christmas
[Music]
[Applause]
this year I'm excited about Blake
Shelton's new reissue of Cheers it's
Christmas which features a new song
written by his girlfriend Gwen Stefani
in fact she also recorded Christmas Eve
for her new album now I'm not picking
favorites but here's Blake's version for
you country lovers
[Music]
angel saying
I'm feeling
[Music]
again for you
Christmasy
Christmasy
and throwing it back to the year 2000
when even the Grinch was no match for
Faith Hill where are you Christmas
became an instant classic when she sang
with Cindy Lou Who
high above Whoville
[Music]
last but certainly not least Reba Kelly
Clarkson and Trisha Yearwood make an
epic trio on what is undoubtedly one of
the best Christmas songs of all time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
whoa did y'all get chills just now cuz I
definitely did if you haven't seen that
full performance on YouTube go find it
it's got almost 17 million hits and for
very very good reason it is also
featured on Reba's brand new my kind of
christmas album which is out right now
thank you for watching guys come back
and see us again next Friday we are
gonna have another very special holiday
performance for you from the stunning
Danielle Bradbery and you are not gonna
want to miss it
see you that
[Music]